"Зелений" тариф - розцінка, за якою держава купує
у підприємств і приватних осіб струм,
вироблений з альтернативних джерел енергії.
Тариф встановлюється законом і
прив’язаний до курсу євро.
Ціна залежить від виду генеруючої установки та
дати введення її в експлуатацію.
Приміром, "сонячний" тариф - складає 15 євроцентів
за кіловат-годину, "вітровий" - 10.
"Зелений" тариф покликаний заохочувати людей
та бізнес ставити вітряки чи сонячні батареї,
а інвесторів - вкладати гроші у
відновлювальну енергетику в Україні.
Адже такі проекти дуже затратні.
В Україні "зелений тариф" в рази вищий, ніж на Заході.
Знизити ціну не дозволяє відсутність конкуренції,
пояснюють експерти.
У Європі, приміром, поширена
практика тарифних аукціонів.
Право збудувати об’єкт з видобування
відновлювальної енергії отримує інвестор,
який запропонував найнижчий тариф.
Поки що енергія атому та вугілля – дешевші.
Утім ніхто не враховує шкоди довкіллю
і здоров’ю людей, ризики техногенних катастроф,
а також витрати на поводження
з радіоактивними відходами.
Тому розвиток альтернативних джерел  енергії
у довгостроковій перспективі має більше переваг
і з економічної,  і з екологічної точок зору.
В Україні на "зеленому" тарифі поки що
заробляє насамперед великий бізнес.
Поблема в тому, що до цієї галузі
причетні чимало політиків.
Як зазначають у громадському русі "Чесно",
у Верховній Раді сформувалася потужна
група "зелених" лобістів.
Однак за останній рік суттєво зросла кількість
приватних господарств, які видобувають і продають
переважно енергію сонця.